texas governor greg abbott joins us now
from austin governor thank you so much
for joining us i know you got a lot
going on too
i was watching you last night and you
were saying to your your people in the
state of texas
those of you in harm's way get out of
harm's way did they pay attention to you
did they listen you know they did we had
well over five thousand maybe as many as
ten thousand people who evacuated
an early report uh which may be
premature but
as of now we have no reports of loss of
life
we do have search and rescue teams going
throughout the entire area
as we speak looking to see if there's
anybody who needs to be rescued
but because so many people did evacuate
especially from the
beaumont port arthur orange area it
probably means that we were able to
escape this devastating storm
without a loss of life oh i hope that
continues you know yesterday we heard
the experts saying an unsurvivable storm
surge i'd never even heard that phrase
before
and it gave me chills is was it as bad
there as
as they had predicted well
early on it looked like the beaumont
port arthur area may be taking the brunt
of the storm
over the past six hours before the storm
came across shore
it moved a little bit more on the
louisiana side
so it did not turn out as bad as was
earlier anticipated however
even as we're speaking right now the
storm continues to rip
through east texas and so texans are in
danger as we speak
right now and they need to continue to
take cover as tornadoes and heavy storms
are ripping through there east texas has
many tall trees
and many of which have been downed
already people need to be very vigilant
still as we're speaking
tall trees in texas everything's big in
texas i'm not surprised to hear that but
how is covet affecting your efforts
because i was hearing reports that
people are afraid to go to shelters
because they're afraid of kova do you
have enough shelters and what is the
situation
with covet in the shelters the good news
is we have abundant shelters one thing
that we learned
from hurricane hannah that came through
texas last month is
the best way for people to shelter in a
hurricane during covet
is not in the large shelters but instead
in hotel rooms where families can
isolate together
without exposing themselves to others
and we occupied
thousands upon thousands of hotel rooms
across the entire
region where people were able to
evacuate to
and so right now uh it is looking pretty
good i know in the aftermath of
hurricane hannah
there was actually a reduction in the
number of people who tested positive for
kobe 19 we hope the same
occurrence will happen here governor
it's anthony mason uh i'm curious how
soon you think you'll be able to get
emergency crews out to the scenes there
and and then did you in texas uh get the
same sort of initial reports that the
storm surge
was not as bad as originally feared
so we have rescue crews that are
operating as we speak right now they
were pre-positioned
hurricanes and unfortunately i guess are
something that we're accustomed to
dealing with
and we were well prepared in advance
those rescue teams
are involved right now making sure that
they're restoring power
restoring and protecting lives and we
are already going to begin
the rebuilding process one reason why
we're able to move so quickly
is because the storm surge was not as
bad as was initially anticipated
all right governor abbott thanks so much
for being with us